et ce soir coup de projecteur sur le bel
itinéraire de momo arrivée à mayotte à
l'âge de 10 ans le leader des new
gravity est devenu un as du parcours
cette discipline qui consiste à franchir
des obstacles de toutes sortes dans la
ville et il se produit aujourd'hui sur
les plus grandes scènes de lille jean
marc collienne et laurent fignon le
rencontrer le spectacle s'intitule the
suite web c'est la nouvelle création de
new gravite une bande de jeunes qui
s'amusaient à faire du parcours dans la
rue et qui se retrouve aujourd'hui sur
une des plus prestigieuses scènes de
lille le leader de new gravity s'appelle
saïd totaux mohamed alias momo
petit retour en arrière sur son histoire
tu as le jardin est là bas
c'est un spot mythique pour nous avons
agrandi avec moi j'habitais là quartier
vauban à saint denis
momo avait 14 ans c'est un gars qui qui
m'a appelé pour me dire viens on va on
va s'entraîner ici quoi un type enflammé
la porte était grand 1er mai des métiers
du grand est le premier alto et ne
tapais la lune c'est ça voilà alors
salle animons salto fétiche c'est mon
salto préférées
[Musique]
m'arrive en 2005 parmi de 10 en 10 ans
quel souvenir gardes tu de cette période
là de ce moment là comment arriver
puisque mon intégration à l'école quand
le prix mais c'est difficile
facile du tout comme mitterrand l'école
d'études montrent également un mode 2
c'est qu'il faut pas s'asseoir
récréation pour trois mois tout seul
des petits
[Musique]
mettez cause du shibushi le shibushi de
mayotte le malgache de mayotte et
combien j'ai visité gagne pas cause
créole des guêpes à cause de français
technip à cause du shimaoré mare.de
m'apprendre tout tissu mettez tout y est
hérétique et comme toute maman de la
star j'ai vu là-bas à l'aca c'est mon
premier frisson mon premier premier salt
ouvriers la donne au moins l'ont
maintenant quand on sait qu'ils moschino
gravity ah bah ouais c'est ben henda il
fait salle tall est vraiment terrible
n'a plus ce côté genre assas événement
aurait fait ça c'est plus pratique ça
mais c'est vraiment montrer une autre
image de nous quand tu ne l'est pas que
ben de mou noël n'est pas que ben
voleurs ici que sa poule et fier mais
très fier jusqu'à deux fois mis les
mycoses dote les deux puisque les pas
l'effort les ports
la formule femme a fait sa nou té
étaient trois en france 34 avoir fait ça
en extérieur
brenna 4000 bébés mon record c'est 12
journée a commencé à la wii pour le
prise courant car l'histoire de new
gravity
c'est d'abord une histoire de prises
électriques sur la presse et la télé et
c'est pour ça que la bande s'est
installé un jour à l'ombre du théâtre de
champ fleuri
parce qu'il y avait moyen brancher la
musique
[Musique]
tous les jours momo lille ou tanguy et
les autres s'entraîner sur la plaine de
jeux et tous les jours pascal montrouge
le directeur du théâtre les voyettes en
passant
[Musique]
mais gardons le toit le même seul
parquet et puis bah je vais au théâtre
et à tous les jours enfin souvent un
débat zot en train de répéter la même
cause a pris ce courant dit c'est bon je
suis allé voir ses intérêts et ceux là
ils m'ont dit c'est new gravity vous a
vraiment connu gamin quoi je 15 ans
qu'un avis alors comment les 13 ans
13-14 ans 90 nous comme été dit ici la
hauteur du théâtre j'annoncerai d'y
envoyer le théâtre j'y vois là se dire
allez on va dedans ou même jouer devant
pour pascal mais vous appelez le temple
ça pour moi c est aujourd'hui
momo franchi fièrement les portes du
temple car après s'être fait connaître
dans les festivals comme big up 9 7 4
new gravity est devenu artiste associé
des théâtres départementaux
je suis doué et leur deuxième spectacle
sous la direction cette fois du
chorégraphe kevin jean
il ajouté
ils sont tous les jours de gérer des
comptes de gamins oit dans le groupe des
six ou dix ballons vers 18 heures mais
bon là il vient d'où nous venons money
money définitif issenlor well et fille
sont corrects mais les gars sont là mon
dieu
les gars ont cédé président des
présidents moi c'est où le chef de la
bande
lévis 2 pas toujours facile à des fois
me plais à la débauche de football liens
web watts le ton équipe au complet
beaucoup et et à leurs enfants nous
échappe aux autres buts pour le
spectacle ils seront cinq sur scène deux
filles et trois garçons
[Musique]
ce soir c'est la dernière répétition
avant la première du nouveau spectacle
de new gravity
après l'échauffement kevin le
chorégraphe donne ses dernières
consignes prenez le temps au début de
vous connecter de bien vous regardez sur
salto restait pas figée où vous étiez
vous pouvez tourner la tête ou que vous
et vous pouvez vous regardez écoutez
vous regardez vous à l'impro comme vous
savez le faire et quand le grand jour
arrive
et maintenant
ce sont des traces alors les marmailles
ravageur de new gravity font leur entrée
dans une salle pleine à craquer ce soir
devant 800 spectateurs
c'est leur vie qu'ils jouent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]